[Music]
I'm Christmas Flint human female I think
you'd like me I think you'd wanna be my
friend dad think I could be part alien
I sure as heck opener how are you out
your Christmas good afternoon
birdies who's excited for Jamboree
there's something special this year an
opportunity to be a part of science
this is dr. Prasad all the way from NASA
we are putting together a record of life
to launch into space we will be
recording people at the Jamboree raise
your hands if you like to think about
outer space peckers will be birdie Scout
Jamboree is a talent show is that you or
is trash you would have been good for
you to be around to other girls but
knows outrage you like one of them
hillbillies
Joseph thought to be birdies not a girl
but says you have to be to make a troupe
we need a minimum of four steps smash
this to come to house the most poor
struggling pulls the air yes miss Eileen
relates to glory you just setting
yourself up for you a little hard to get
Brooke no set myself up to change my
whole life I can be birdies birdies have
a strict quality code my boos are
quality though the only number left in
the state of Georgia is zero soon
welcome troop zero
y'all got even one badge each to go to
Jamboree buy my cookies talkin be a
woman of substance that's not appear
police really don't you before you get
the money booth y'all suck happy and
girl you ain't got nobody show us happy
better be that way dress Jesus what kind
of world would it be if every strange
little girl thought she could just do
whatever she wanted this is what God
gave me to work with and I'm gonna make
it beautiful cuz it's mine
well we look forward to seeing what you
look girls are made in I hope what is it
angel we're made of organs tissues don't
do nothing half-ass I won't do anything
what's happening us
[Music]